une envie de confronter sa pièce à
l'oeil d'un jury aguerris l'a poussé à
s'inscrire auprès célimène elle n'y
croit pas trop elle a tort cette idée de
boîtes qui serait en qui contiendrait
l'esprit d'une personne dans laquelle on
rentre par par strates par profondeur un
peu comme dans comme dans la vie on
connaît jamais vraiment les personnes je
l'avais déjà développée donc je n'ai pas
présenté spécialement pour le prix en
fait j'ai vu je crois dans le journal
puis avait un concours et puis ben je
m'étais dit que ça pouvait être
intéressant de présenter la pièce de se
confronter à un jury parce qu'ils en ce
qu'il en pensait une pièce remplie de
symboles qui accroche le regard et
éveille la curiosité et ont cette
reconnaissance alice y voit une double
récompense celle du monde artistique
mais tout simplement celle de la réunion
est une reconnaissance des pairs
détesté des artistes professionnels de
l'art et ça veut dire aussi que mon
travail a été
remarquée et donc forcément c'est
gratifiant d'après le personnage s'est
lui-même c'était pour moi
assez
bas j'ai trouvé ça gratifiant passer un
personnage de la réunion une femme voilà
avec du caractère et du coup ça m'a
permis aussi de oued avoir une
reconnaissance des artistes d'ici et des
sas et c'était un plus ce point parce
que c'est vrai que je pas native du
guide une oeuvre primée c'est aussi le
regard qui se tourne vers son auteur
l'artiste peut enfin donner libre cours
à ses inspirations ses poussa à ces
valeureux temps this man après il ya eu
aussi du coup l'acquisition de
l'artothèque voit que ça c'était
important aussi pour moi parce que ça
veut dire entrer dans un musée
qui est pas des moindres quand même à la
réunion c'est un musée voilà qui
s'intéressent à la création actuelle est
donc bah ça c'était un honneur pour moi
2005 2011 un passage par la suisse pour
parfaire sa technique une résidence au
musée de villèle jusqu'à 2000 surtout
une création acheté par le musée des
arts appliqués j'ai autres aussi une
création d'un vase qui a été acquis par
le musée du mudac donc ces deux musées d
art application n'est plus grands musées
européens au niveau en arts appliqués
donc tout ce qui concerne le design et
puis aussi la céramique donc voilà il ya
plein de choses qui se passent bien et
des projets plein la tête alice se
croirait presque au pays des merveilles
dans sa petite case de saint pierre elle
peut désormais se permettre de laisser
voguer son imagination comme ici avec
sept sculptures étonnantes une veuve
noire entrée en temps madame desbassyns